oh my God I did something here I might
just patent this okay I need to make a
cocktail not just any cocktail but a
cocktail that I feel like best
represents one of my best friends this
is an idea I got from Tik Tok I saw this
trend going around of for girls night
each friend coming in with a drink that
best describes their ex and so for
example if there was like a really
fruity drink but but it had a lot of
tequila in it it'd be called like the
liar or something like that because it
really like it's Sneaky and you don't
really taste a tequila until your job
and so I was like Hey Y'all let's do a
night like that but let's describe one
another and I completely forgot to
introduce myself I'm sorry for that my
name is Nia I'm the black s engineer and
I talk about tech en coding in a
lifestyle way so stick around hit that
subscribe button and let's make some
drinks this is who I am assigned to this
is who I'm going to try to bottle up
into cocktail form and let's see how it
goes I'm also doing this completely
blind I was like I feel like it'll be
more fun if I kind of just do a little
scientific lab over here and see what
works and then when finally I get to a
concoction into a recipe I like then
actually making it officially they
coming in about 4 hours so I feel like
that's enough time yeah let's see so
what I got for this I got some Peach
Moscato cuz she's cute as a peach I got
a
tequila I got a Mescal more because I
like Mescal I thought it could be a good
liquor to add to this drink some proo
and some dragon fruit sparkling water oh
and the best thing yet that I love so
much let me show youall I got some
cotton candy I thought it would be
really cool to shape the cotton and
candy like a cloud because she's
traveling always check out her Instagram
freedom to explore I think it would be a
cool thing to put on top of the drink as
like yeah like you're always in the
clouds cuz you travel so
much okay I didn't buy more than I
needed to for example this prco is just
a little bit it's three of us girls
including me coming over tonight and so
I felt like this was enough I say that
to say I don't have much room for error
so I'm going to try the tequila first
because if I do like it and if it is
good with this drink maybe I won't even
try with the Mescal so let's
see
I'm going to use this for measuring I
just moved and so I actually don't have
any type of measuring cup unfortunately
let me start
out with just the tiniest bit of
tequila okay so kind of like at the
halfway
mark this in
there I'll put a full amount
[Music]
right let me taste
this okay no it's sweet it's
[Music]
sweet I'll put
two let me taste this before I add in
the sparkling water because I feel like
how this taste will impact that decision
if it's too strong I'll add some
sparkling water but if it's not too
strong maybe I'll go in with something
else I'll I'll see
cheers
okay okay you can definitely taste the
tequila so I will be adding in the
sparkling water but it's super sweet
it's really really sweet extremely
peachy so no I this was this was a good
decision this was a good call
oh my
gosh this is fantastic okay the
sparkling water added just the right
amount of like airiness that I want for
this drink and so what I was thinking I
add the C candy just like on top I'll
squish it and see how it
looks this looks so cute it's a lot
denser than I thought it would be man I
don't know the last time I had fun on
[Music]
Candy wow this is good okay let me take
a little
bit because I need it still for
tonight okay let's
see how would I do this
does that look
good it kind of looks just placed to
there let
me here let
me do it like this
maybe does that look
better oh that looks good looks like a
cloud right does it look like a
cloud I feel like feel like it
does yeah no I think that's cute
okay wow I did so much better than I
thought I would I really truly was just
winging It Whatever ingredient I saw in
the store I was like okay add that to
the basket so I'm really really happy
with this um so yes this is the Michin
let me see how it tastes like with the
con candy do I drink it do I drink it
with the con candy inside or like take a
piece I don't know
okay well that doesn't work cuz then it
just let me just blop it plop it in
there oh that's cool wait a
minute that's so cool I didn't think
it'd look like that oh my God this is
the best drink ever oh my God I did
something here I might just patent this
if y'all would like to try it you got
the ingredients and everything I'll put
them down in the description box below
but I really did something there I
really ate that up so Micha if you don't
like it that's on
you all of us are receiving a drink of
what that person thinks exemplifies us
so I'm really curious to see what my
drink is around 6:15 I'll get all the
drinks ready so that they are repaired
by the time they get here
and yeah hopefully it's a fun
[Music]
night